[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
German automakers are always president
car shows in China whether in Beijing or
as this time Shanghai are Carmen Montes
kirat says Chinese automakers are often
accused of copying the designs of other
brands like with the car behind him but
he says Chinese car makers are in some
respects very advanced and even ahead of
the rivals as highlighted once again by
this car and no other Auto Show in the
world has so many electric and
self-driving cars as here in Shanghai
German car giant Volkswagen unveiled the
I D cross concept car a world premiere
the man in charge of brand management at
VW have IDs says the ID Cross will go
into production by 2020
the idea he says the ID cross is based
on VW's architecture for electric models
there's plenty of space for the battery
for passengers and for cargo
there is no combustion engine it's all
electric the operating concept is
completely new the vehicle will be
constantly linked to the Internet and
therefore offer new services and behave
intelligently it's also ready for when
self-driving comes in Auto Shanghai has
become increasingly important for the
global industry
asalamu Saudi CEO Rupert Adler says the
quality of the car shows in China has
increased significantly in recent years
Shanghai is very international and
suitable for world premieres he's
pleased about that because he finds him
very attractive here there's lots of new
ideas many electric vehicles
digitalization is another big theme so
areas of innovation that Audi is also
focused on so it's in Tina Watson's
fender the winsome once automobile
segment paving howdy is also here with a
new all-electric concept vehicle the
e-tron sport back it has one electric
motor on the front axle and two at the
rear so it packs a punch
and not to be outdone Skoda has also
brought an electric car to Shanghai the
vision II is scooters contribution to a
cleaner more sustainable future Montes
says you may be thinking didn't I just
see the same vehicle from Volkswagen the
answer is yes and no the two vehicles
share the same platform VW's modular
electric toolkit but there are
differences in details and the body line
give this done gone off what does she do
the vision he is SCOTUS first
all-electric concept vehicle said have
Friedrichshafen is also here as a maker
of parts it's vital for the car industry
we have a two major themes we're talking
about about automated driving active and
passive safety systems being combined
and supporting that sort of technology
and we're talking about driveline
technologies in particular a mobility ZF
produces everything from automatic
transmissions suitable for hybrid
vehicles control electronics and
electric axle drives so it's a valuable
partner for companies looking to get
into a mobility
montes says chinese buyers like
elsewhere don't only shop with their
heads but also their hearts so fast
expensive cars are still in the
all-electric concept car from Bentley
uses luxury CEO of condor himer says
it's equipped with three electric motors
and a large battery allowing a range of
500 kilometers this is what the first
all-electric Bentley could look like and
it's certainly not slow the EXP 12 speed
6 e convertible delivers the kind of
performance you'd expect from a regular
gas-powered 12 cylinder Bentley Porsche
is also getting in on the act with its
Panamera a hybrid and the new Panamera
stationwagon
Porsche CEO Oliver bloomer says this is
a whole new segment for the company
linking great comfort with the sporty
nature of the Panamera basic vehicle
it's the first Panamera with five seats
but includes many genes from the 911 and
the 918 Spyder and Porsche has also made
an extra-long Panamera the executive
exclusively for the Chinese market
the new s-class from Mercedes also had
its world premiere here in Shanghai it's
not an electric vehicle although a
plug-in hybrid version is plant the
flagship vehicle is the Maybach s 680
designed to be the epitome of luxury
it's not there Sadie's bus diva said she
says the s-class has always been the
ultimate an automobile construction it
says many would agree that Mercedes has
once again lived up to that standard
every time you think you've reached the
limit he says you discover more progress
as possible Mercedes has also bought a
concept car built on the 8th class
platform says the Chinese government
shocked the automobile industry when it
announced plans for a compulsory
electric vehicle quota which seemed to
come very suddenly
but Montes thinks it was a move in the
right direction and Auto Shanghai shows
it's working with electric vehicles and
plug-in hybrids everywhere you look
electric auto sewed up like a new breed
fat soybean
[Music]
Venetia anchor car tester Android
simmerman says when he thinks of
Cadillacs he thinks of oversized cars
with lots of chrome and luxury to spare
though these days Cadillac seems to see
itself a little differently
of course the carmaker's ats-v also
features chrome and some classic
Cadillac design cues but take just one
look at the 5,500 euro carbon black
sports package and you can see why the V
stands for the ATS --is high-performance
version this vehicle can easily give
American muscle cars like the Camaro and
Corvette a run for their money
[Music]
the ats-v is powered by a v6 engine with
an output of 346 kilowatts inspires
shouldn't be too environmentally
conscious or cash-strapped as official
fuel consumption is 11.6 liters per 100
kilometers and it's bound to be even
higher in real-life conditions Andre had
figured that a Cadillac like this would
automatically come with a big v8 engine
instead he has to make do with two
cylinders less though the remaining six
cylinders are turbocharged and deliver
high performance the ats-v also comes
with Cadillacs magnetic ride control
this adaptive damping system constantly
monitors road conditions using
electronic sensors and quickly adjust
the suspension accordingly the Cadillac
plies from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour
in 3.9 seconds and rounds curves with
ease that makes it competition for bmw
m3 and mercedes-amg c63 Andre says
unlike those German models the ATS v's
top speed is encamped at 250 kilometers
an hour so with an aggressive driver
behind the wheel this Cadillac could
force its German competitors to get out
of the passing lane
unlike its German competitors carbon
ceramic brakes aren't an option with the
ats-v still the ones supplied by Italian
brake specialist Brembo do a fine job
cadillac is marketing the ats-v as a
track capable vehicle and andre can
believe it's suitable for racing even on
roads like this the car goes like the
wind
he thinks it's a nice gimmick to have
the button that switches off the ESP
mounted right on the steering wheel as
it's normally tucked away on the dash or
in the center console by putting it here
cadillac is making it clear that this is
a car you can push to its limits that's
das auto we deem to own a problem adding
transportation equal in constant thanks
to its tires which were custom-made for
the ats-v the American model keeps a
firm grip on the road even when
accelerating out of turns Andre says the
ATS v's Achilles heel is its
transmission while its competitors offer
either manual or dual clutch
transmissions here you have to make do
with an 8-speed automatic you can shift
the gearbox manually but it's still no
match for the competition in terms of
shift time and precision
he thinks the competition's dual clutch
transmissions are much nicer
this light and nice to shoot me to
Doppler couples could dream about a
confidence
[Music]
inside performance meets luxury
there's magnesium paddle shifters and
piano black trim drivers can recharge
their cell phones on a hidden wireless
charging mat the seats are made from
suede and leather Andre says that for
him this car is a pleasant surprise and
a real knockout in terms of performance
the Cadillac measures up to its German
competitors and has a similar
entry-level price what this Cadillac
doesn't have is a long and confusing
list of options what it does have is the
prestige and uniqueness of a Cadillac
because in Germany German cars can be
found on practically every street corner
whereas this one is a rare sight deepen
in Deutschland Tuscany and this
prestigious powerhouse can be had for a
starting price at just under 70,000
euros here
[Music]
SUVs are many people's favorite vehicle
cars that look like they're tailored for
especially active athletic people year
for year they topped the list of newly
licensed cars
[Music]
we took a look at six SUVs in the
compact segment that are riding this
wave of success
[Music]
see that's Attica and opals mocha X are
both new on the market we went to
northern Denmark to put them to the test
and compare them with their rivals the
more companies offer SUVs the greater
the diversity with the v40 cross country
Volvo sets the standard for Noble s the
top version with 180 kilowatts and
all-wheel-drive was our favourite in
this comparison but the Volvo's power
and dynamism are the only aspects that
topped the rest so does the price our
test car broke the 50000 euro barrier
with ease but Volvo fans get something
for their money
cool Scandinavian design finest
materials and good craftsmanship the
cross country is one point two
centimeters higher off the ground than
the normal v40 that's not only practical
it looks good to see outcomes late to
the SUV boom but not too late the new
Atika
is well equipped its form is an
eccentric like its brother the Seattle
Eon it's more generically pleasing it's
the only SUV in our comparison that does
without all-wheel drive like the Volvo
it does not come with a diesel version
here in Denmark we don't miss either the
Atika gets points for its well
harmonized DSG transmission very
comfortable seats and good craftsmanship
we were so impressed by the
rough-and-ready atmosphere enhanced home
harbor that we used the floating duck as
the backdrop for the Jeep renegade and
Toyota rav4
[Music]
visually the cheap renegade is the most
eccentric in our comparison it's many
curves and playful details reveal an
Italian pedigree and that cuddly design
is popular since 1941 cheap has stood
for off-road capability and the renegade
is no exception the Jeep is a rough
tough guy it's 125 kilowatt diesel
engine makes it hard to slow down and
it's the only SUV in our test that can
really say it's truly at home offroad
[Music]
the latest Toyota rav4 generation has
had a moderate facelift
it also has better insulation and the
quality of materials in the interior has
improved all of that and a hybrid engine
and all-wheel drive come for a fair
price of just above thirty thousand
euros the standard rate for does okay on
mild off-road tours but better not try
that with the hybrid the hybrid
all-wheel very and simply has an
additional electric motor on the rear
axle which kicks in automatically when
needed but that can't do the job of a
constant four-wheel drive the focus here
was clearly on fuel efficiency and with
an average fuel consumption of just five
litres per 100 kilometers The Rave force
definitely the thrifty as' the SUVs
we're testing the South Korean firm kia
occupies a stable niche in the SUV
segment the Sportage is the company's
best seller primarily because of its
pleasant design that's the work of a
team around designer Peter Schreyer who
used to style Volkswagens
the interior is pleasing too but what
ensures success is that the technology
lives up to what the overall design
promises the powerful 136 kilowatt
diesel engine and the classic automatic
torque conversion transmission are as
convincing as the adequately comfortable
suspension the Kia Sportage is a
well-built SUV with plenty of optional
features opals crossover mocha now
sports an X in its logo and new LED
headlamps if you're willing to pay extra
it's available with several assist
systems that make driving not only
easier but also safer an important
advance over the old mocha is the Sat
Nav with touchscreen but our test car
with all the works would also cost more
than 30,000 euros with its 100 kilowatt
diesel engine the mocha moves right
along our only problem was that the
otherwise acceptable level of comfort
suffered a bit from the big 18-inch
wheels
SUVs remain popular but diesel engines
are on the way out the SIA proves that a
good gasoline engine can be a
consolation Toyota's hybrid engine and
The Rave 4 packs a lot of bang for a few
bucks another trend is the all assist
popping up in compact SUVs but almost
none of these SUVs are really suited for
off-road environments only the Jeep is
keen to preserve its off-road roots
[Music]
making affordable small cars for the
common person is an Italian specialty
this tradition began in the 1930s with
the first series production compact to
boast a four-cylinder engine the Fiat
500
better known as the topolino our classic
car expert Chris Taub our explains the
origins of the little mouse he says that
a 1933 Fiat patriarch Giovanni AG Nelly
commissioned a 29 year old engineer
named auntie Jia cosa to develop an
economical small car if silly Christ was
to be not more than 5,000 lira just half
that of the Fiat Pamela the company's
cheapest model at the time and the new
car needed to be more comfortable
powerful and good-looking than the
competition from Germany and France
Krista feels that was a tall order for a
young engineer but when I went into
production in 1936 the Fiat 500
fulfilled all of the criteria but one it
cost eight thousand nine hundred lira
not five thousand still a pretty fair
price christophe thanks
beginning in 1936 the little Fiat was
assembled on a modern production line at
the carmaker's lingotto plant in Turin
by 1954 some five hundred twenty
thousand a B and C muddled top Elena's
had been built aside from the sedan the
500 was also available as a station
wagon initially called the Jardin IVA
and later the Belvedere but how did the
Fiat 500 come to be known as the
topolino that stuff says that in the
early 1930s Walt Disney's Mickey Mouse
became popular in Italy but due to
licensing issues
Mickey was known here as topolino or
Mouse lino and because the 500s
freestanding headlights bear a slight
resemblance to Mickey's years it soon
was given the nickname popolino
the Fiat 500 proved to be robust durable
and fuel efficient it has rear-wheel
drive like most models of its day but
other than that its basic structure is
very similar to that of modern compacts
Christophe says the tapa lino seats to
adults comfortably with space for
luggage behind the seats there is no
trunk lid you could fit two children in
back here but Christoph says Italians
love to fill their totally nose up to
the roof and if it had a nice soft top
like this one and even beyond that no
one cared that the maximum payload was
just 50 kilos but then Fiat had sold it
as a fully fledged car by 1938 Fiat had
equipped the axles with longer leaf
springs so carrying lots of cargo was no
longer an issue the magazine motor in
sport says the tapa lino could travel
100 kilometers on seven and a half
liters of gas the best fuel consumption
ever seen at the time later 500 B models
like this one used just 5 litres per 100
clicks though likely a bit more when
going uphill
but spare cows kids lighter we are
[Music]
when it comes to design Christophe says
that Topolino is clearly influenced by
the streamlined shapes that were popular
in the 1930s even the door handles are
sunken to improve the car's drag
coefficient he notes that only when the
body is secured to the light ladder
frame does the top Aledo have the
necessary stiffness it was a clever way
of reducing the cars weight which also
lowered its cost and fuel consumption
for the same reason parts of the frame
were perforated a technique that had
previously only been used in airplanes
and race cars and the car also used
these little 15-inch wheels especially
made by Pirelli which made the car look
big and dynamic - hi Nana
Vista Pollino belongs to the relatively
rare B series which was only built from
1948 to 1949
it's much-loved retractable textile roof
came as standard and a redesigned
dashboard pepped up the cars Spartan
interior but the models most important
improvements are to be found under the
hood if yet fitfully PR staff says the
main difference between the Fiat 500 B
and its predecessor is the engine while
the a used a side valve engine the be
had overhead valves this technical
innovation gave the car a big power
boost from 13 horsepower to 16.5
horsepower unusually the radiator is
found up here behind the engine enabling
the car to have a sleek and aerodynamic
front end and of course Fiat put the
engine as far forward as possible to
create more interior space so while the
firm was bent on saving money they
didn't scrimp on technology christoph
says the only drawback is the crankshaft
which only has two main bearings so
after just 50,000 kilometers the ancient
often needs an overhaul
[Music]
but the throaty sounding inline
four-cylinder engine has to work pretty
hard
it's 0.6 liters of cubic capacity means
it can reach just 95 kilometers an hour
Christoph says for people with big feet
like him the car is not easy to drive
because the pedals are so close together
but otherwise it's great fun to drive
around within the wind in your hair and
it's day the top foligno impress car
testers - one German magazine praised
its low center of gravity good weight
distribution and great road holding but
first and second gears aren't
synchronized so when down shifting you
really need to double D clutch but
Italians love to do that anyway they
call it londo pietà topple eNOS weren't
just popular in Italy they were exported
around the globe - as far away as China
Australia and the US the little Fiat was
also produced under license by NSU and
Germany steyr poo and Austria and simcha
in France
[Music]
kristef says the top Polina was Italy's
best-selling car until the mid 1950s
some 520,000 were built and brought
mobility to the masses in Italy like the
VW Beetle did in Germany and sit whens
2cv and did in France with its
lightweight construction and quality
technology it was years ahead of the
competition and it established the Fiat
brand as specialists for stylish high
quality small cars making the tow polino
a milestone in automotive history
Dante Jia cosa the tapa Leno's creator
worked for Fiat for almost half a
century developing dozens of other
models for the car maker Fiat later
revived the 500 name and continues to
produce 500 bad super minis to this day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]